Õpetaja: Liiga kaugele.
Õpetaja: Tegime asju, punkt.
Õpetaja: Aa, nii
Õpetaja: ee, peeb. Neli on selline asi. Ee, mis tegelikult on ära määrata et See on lihtsalt projekti setup
Õpetaja: töötamiseks oleks vaja installeerida. No jah, okei. See vist on üldse nagu idiootne asi, mida maha võtta. Asi, Mis
Õpetaja: Ah, aga ma räägin ju.
Õpetaja: Tehke lahti, Beeb Neli,
Õpetaja: Ee Bm Neli räägib seda, et ei oleks vaja aga tegelikult, see võtaks nagu ära Siit taskist. Aga nüüd asjad nagu ettevalmistus. Jpa Body Plugin
Õpetaja: Auto Installeri kasutajatel on see kõik olemas. Kooli kasutajatel on kõik olemas hammasratas lahti Teil Ei ole vaja isegi checkida, kellel on kooliasi ja nii edasi Installer töötas.
Õpetaja: Aga põhimõtteliselt Instal. Tal peab olema. Näete jälle mingi loomakene on Classic kutsa, kellel on koer.
Õpetaja: Ja mis te, kellel on? Kass,
Õpetaja: kellel ei ole koera ega kassi, aga on koerainimene
Õpetaja: ja Koeraga kassi on ka kassi. Inimene
Õpetaja: on veits vähem. Vaata, mina olen allergiline. Kaitsele vastu on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, teie uus lemmik sõber on kutsa, et isegi Kellel meeldivad kassid.
Õpetaja: Ülihea? Plugin
Õpetaja: Ee. Mina nägin seda esimest korda siis, kui asi oli Beetas Ja isegi ma ei teadnud ühtegi arendajat, kes Nagu minu tutvusringkonnas seda kasutas.
Õpetaja: Ma nägin seda asja Ma vaatasin veri naiss. Ee, väga hea asi Ee. Vanasti oli kellegi teise oma, tundub et nägi kah sellel asjal väärtust. Nad ostsin need ära. Vaadake, Kes on tegija. Nemad ei olnud need loojad.
Õpetaja: Ma tõstsin selle asja ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on vajalik. Ee, miks, kuidas. Räägime hiljem?
Õpetaja: Ee, Andmebaasi on vaja Jällegi Kõigil on see tegelikult Ee, taustal olemas. Muidu teil rohkem See läheks käimagi. Ahah, see on see koht. Vaata, kus ee, tuleks Ee, panna. Backhand käima. Korra vaadata ka,
Õpetaja: sest väike end on seadistatud.
Õpetaja: Ee, Backend on seadistatud. Ee, niimoodi
Õpetaja: Teil on siin Ee, Source ja Resources all on Application Properties. Rakenduse seaded
Õpetaja: teil on siin juba ära pandud. Et Ole hea. Ühenda andmebaasiga. Vali tee.
Õpetaja: Username on üks, kaks, kolm. See tähendab seda, et kui te panete rakenduse käima siit ülevalt, See on teil kõigil olemas. Vast, kellel ei ole. Räägime teine homme hommikul. Me saame selle ka. Kui te panete selle käima siis ta Ühtlasi üritab luua. Ta kontrollib ühendust andmebaasiga.
Õpetaja: Kui andmebaasi poleks, siis ta lihtsalt kukkus. Pikali Näed. Jäi käima.
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, et ee server paremal pool,
Õpetaja: Ee, kuskil on ka server. Start up, Port Kaheksakümmend, kaheksakümmend.
Õpetaja: Ee, oleks teil kukkunud pikali. Kui midagi ei ole. Kui kukub, siis tuletage meelde Homme hommikul esimese asjana vaatame
Õpetaja: nii. Ee, et selles mõttes see katab ära selle andmebaasi osa.
Õpetaja: Ja hallo, tere, tere, Aa, väga hea, Tuleme peale tööpäeva läbi,
Õpetaja: et käin pangaautomaadist läbi, et Ee, võtta sulli ka. Mis ma teile võlgnen
Õpetaja: või on seal vahet?
Õpetaja: No siis öelge öelge summa.
Õpetaja: Mhmh, jah. Siis ma tulen järgi ja suhtleme nägemist.
Õpetaja: Telefoni teel saab alati küsida.
Õpetaja: Tahan teha teile pakkumise. Oo, ei, räägi kord.
Õpetaja: Ee, No nii, ee. Ühesõnaga siin räägitakse, et andmebaasi. Andmebaas peab olemas olema Teil see asi ei töötaks. Kui Ei, oleks
Õpetaja: ee. Räägitakse et siin, on andmebaasi Vajalikud skriptid. Nad Tegelt on projekti juures olemas.
Õpetaja: Infrastructure, kus on Ee olemas. Ee, vanasti pole siin juurde panna, aga nüüd olen jätnud selle kohe olemas, et kui tulla meini alla ja vaadata jaava, on niuke infrastructure, Mis siin sees on? Räägime hiljem,
Õpetaja: aga üks asi on siin. Küll.
Õpetaja: Ee. Projekti struktuur all on kirjeldatud üldine struktuur. Kuidas võiksid failid hakata projektides asetsema? Siin on väikene. Asi on
Õpetaja: tokskaustal, on Database ja script Id. Vaatame neid hiljem. Siin on öeldud, et nad on eraldi. See on nagu back end ile ka enda tehtud Vaata, et kõik, mis peaks, olema.
Õpetaja: Aga põhiline, mis siin nagu hakkab olema, on ee süsteem,
Õpetaja: kuidas ja kus võiks miski olla olemas,
Õpetaja: et Ee, Kuhu tulevad Enkity Klassid?
Õpetaja: Kuhu tulevad? Ee, kontrolleri asjad.
Õpetaja: Kuhu Tulevad Service Id. Ja mis Viisil? Head, Head, head. Ja teil ei ole vaja tegelikult praegu midagi teada.
Õpetaja: Kui hakkas muidugi arendama. Ai, ga, siis päris kasulik on, Niuke. Asi, et on kuskil dokumentides olemas, et ta teab Kuhu üks või teine fail toppida ja mis kirjaviisiga ja nii edasi,
Õpetaja: et põhjus, miks te toas ei ole teil seal nimekirjas, kuna teil Tegelikult projektis on kõik juba ajas
Õpetaja: järgmine sisuline Taask oli siis see, mis siin korra juba läbi käis.
Õpetaja: Ee, alustame taskist nimega Login.
Õpetaja: Ehk Siis peeb viis. Üritan seda pihta saada. Kuidagi
Õpetaja: P viis on siis päris esimene task. Räägitakse, et andmebaasi mudelist mängivad rolli. Ee, tabelid, user Ja role
Õpetaja: loovus. Boss. Teenus, abi. Login
Õpetaja: siis. Ee. Logimisel saadetakse Back and serverile Http boss. Sõnum sellisele aadressile koos Request Body. Ga
Õpetaja: Kus on username. String Password String välja saadetavast sõnumist.
Õpetaja: No need peaksid juba veits nagu tuttavad olema. Teil
Õpetaja: Ehk siis meie sellest frontend ist võetakse Username Password. Meie saame selle ära realiseerida. Ee, vaadata, kas see töötab ja siis saame frontend is ka proovida. Happy Bath.
Õpetaja: Kui andmebaas on Olemas vastava username ja Passwordiga Active kasutaja. Kasutaja Usertabeli veeru. Staatusväärtus on A.
Õpetaja: Siis tagastab teenust. Hdp status kahesaja ja responsobjekti, kus on alljärgnevad. Väljad Role name.
Õpetaja: Kui selliste kasutada ei leitud, siis tagastab teenus.
Õpetaja: Saatus nelisada kolme päris põõtsu objektiga, kus on järgivad väiad.
Õpetaja: Mis see String Error String Ee Paigutamine nokaga pani ka kohe otsa. Sinna.
Õpetaja: Kas te teate, miks see nii on üldse empaatia?
Õpetaja: Ei ole, Ee, tegelikult on Survival. Ee, hõimu või karjainst.
Õpetaja: Ee huntade pealt. Väga hea, lihtne näide. Ee, Kui seal üks hunt hakkab niiöelda haigutama ja ilmutab niiöelda väsimus, märke, siis tegelikult see sügavamalt hingamine peaks justkui ka enda nagu ergutama. Ei tea, kas see päriselt töötab või mitte,
Õpetaja: ja siis ongi see, Et kui üks juba tunneb vajadust, et olla nagu alert, siis äkki kõik peaksid olema allergia instinkt.
Õpetaja: Väidetavalt ma pole Chatiga sel teemal arutanud, Kas see on nagu mingi, kus ma selle info olen saanud? Ja kas see peab paika? Aga
Õpetaja: on öeldud, et ee, veohalduseks kasuta enumit I sisuks läheb vale Kasutaja. Nimi ja parool ja error. Koodiks läheb incore. Vanasti ma veel mingeid numbreid Panin sinna. Enam pole vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee Päriselus on ka. Ee see, niimoodi, et ee, süsteemid tegelikult väina väid saadavad teineteistele ka mingisuguseid. Noh, teateid Aga mis rohkem süsteeme huvitavad? On Hoopis mingid numbrilised väärtused.
Õpetaja: Mingi error koodid või mis iganes, ehk kuidas? Nagu üks süsteem programmeerib teise süsteemi vastu oma pea haldust vaata
Õpetaja: Ehk Siis selles mõttes, et see see sõnum võib tulla Eesti keeles. Vene keeles, inglise keeles. Aga see error kood jääb alati samaks. See on See Kaine mõte
Õpetaja: ja süsteemid ei taha kunagi niimoodi, et sa saad mingisuguse teksti ja selle lause sisse, et kui tuleb mingi messager ei leidnud kasutajat või midagi taolist, et kuidas siis süsteem peab käituma? Pigem dokumenteeritakse ära mingid kokku lepitud väärtused staatused, koodid, või mis iganes ja Selle põhjal see süsteem toimetab.
Õpetaja: Ee, minul oli vanasti, niimoodi et näiteks ee oli error kood numbriline. Ja sellises olukorras tuli lihtsalt kood. Üks Üks kokkulepitud kood.
Õpetaja: Aga ma mingi hetk. Ma muutsin selle ära. Vaata, et las ta siis kasutab parem eluväärtust. Ee, päris süsteemides olen ka näinud siis nagu mõlemast, et miks? Need üsna lühikesed koodid. Aga nad lihtsalt mingit sõna ikkagi sisaldavad. Või? Vahel on ka tõesti mingeid numbreid, ongi numbreid. Sellepärast, et see võib ka lõppkasutajale minna,
Õpetaja: Võib kasutada mingisuguse imeliku errori. Tal on mingi väga imelik olukord, mis sa realiseerunud, mis on ära programmeeritud, aga teid nagu ei tohiks justkui sündida. Vaata, on ju? Sest ta saab ju kirjutada kuskile. Ma ei tea kliendi toele. Vaata, ma ei tea, mul näitab mingit niukest Errorit. Ee, minul Niukene asi ei tööta. Siis on. Ahah,
Õpetaja: mis te seal tegite? Täpsemalt Vaata et Noh, proovime nagu aru saada, kuidas see viga nagu tekkis keegi õnnetu hing saab siis selle emaili kuskilt kätte lõpuks ja hakkab siis selle sisuliselt otsa vaatama, onju? Arenduse poole pealt koodi tasandil. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: kuskil on tekkinud mingisugune viga, mida me oleme kainda nagu näinud, et võib juhtuda, aga seda ei peaks juhtuma. Küsimus, nagu et miks? See nagu juhtus või mis toimub, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Noh, mingisugused pidepunktid on ju, Need on siis kuskil dokumentatsioonis. Üldjuhul kajastatud ka. Ee, kuskil jumal teab, kus kohas.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis räägitakse. Seda siin on mingid näited. Siis näidis sõnumitest. Ee, on hästi. Admin on hästi. Customer on error.
Õpetaja: Appi dokumentatsioon.
Õpetaja: Ee teenuse kokkuvõtvaks. Kirjelduseks võiks Panna sisse. Logimine tagastab username. I See on osa koodi baasist, Mis siin praegu räägitakse? Teenuse detailsemaks kirjelduseks võiks panna süsteemist, otsitakse username ja abil kasutajat Kelle konto on ka aktiivne, Kui vastet ei leitav, visatakse viga error koodiga.
Õpetaja: Status kakssada, nelisada kolm prol, ja näidiskood.
Õpetaja: Ee, lihtsalt näidiskood. Et Kuidas, värk, Kõik, mis me Siin räägime informatsioon Okei,
Õpetaja: Davai. Ee, hakkame pihta. Kasutatakse andmebaasist.
Õpetaja: Mm, hetkel on niimoodi, et kui database Connection It teil ei ole, siis sa Saad selle luua?
Õpetaja: Ee, enamustel. Kes nüüd importisid? Said selle ka kuidagi. Aga muidu on database Niimoodi, et Ee,
Õpetaja: parem Ei, lihtsalt klõps.
Õpetaja: Teeme uue, palun.
Õpetaja: Ja võib teha küll. Jah, või peab. Mis on B? Neli B, viis, Ee, New Brunch. Muidugi, Omanimeline Beeb
Õpetaja: Viis
Õpetaja: peep.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ongi Nüüd on Back end Bank Ennem oli.
Õpetaja: Jaa, nad olid make. Sense ee. Tavaline asi on, kui ma tegin. Ee, kui me tegime, Näiteks
Õpetaja: kui meil oli näiteks Ee Lhv S. Oli rakendus ehk maksete süsteem Backendi mõttes Seal kõik hakkasid Paim.
Õpetaja: Noh, mingi ühendatud variant sellest konkreetsest projektist või või rakendusest.
Õpetaja: Veel viis.
Õpetaja: Kes valesti tegi, ei pea ära kustutama Lokaalset haru saab Rename Ida, parem klõps, Mis iganes
Õpetaja: database Connection on olemas. Kellelgi ei ole käsipüste, kellel on.
Õpetaja: Mõnel peaks olema. Me tegime hiljem nii ühtepidi ja teistpidi õpetustes oli ka, kellel ei olnud, siis tuleb nüüd käsitsi teha.
Õpetaja: Mm, no lihtsam. Moodus on see, kui teil veel on desktop. Il, kas te kõik kasutasid ee? Kas Keegi tegi kõik käsitsi, kes tõstis praegu käepistet. Tal ei ole
Õpetaja: või autoinst. Auto installeriga tegite kõik.
Õpetaja: Jah, siis tal peaks desktop il endiselt olema. Aa, et pole Teeme. See kokkuvõte.
Õpetaja: Desktopi peaks olema valid kokkuvõte installer ist.
Õpetaja: Kui teil on selline url, siis saaks kõik kiiremini käsi püsti, kellel on puudu, aga ei ole niukest asja, Kust pead seda kopida? Ah, mis kurat
Õpetaja: lihtne.
Õpetaja: Ee, General, ole väga.
Õpetaja: Nimel saab veits kiiremini, kui te kopite selle asja.
Õpetaja: Seda on nüüd neil vaja, kellel ei ole seda Connection It
Õpetaja: kuidas Jah, seda saab testida,
Õpetaja: aga jõuame Testimiseni ka. Kas praegult teevad kaasa? Kellel üldse ei ole siin midagi? Kellel on siin mingi Connection ja võibolla on või midagi taolist, te Võite teha mingi refresh Ida või midagi.
Õpetaja: Siis ta võibolla ütleb, et mingi draiver on puudus. See on ka tõenäoline asi, mida peab võibolla Installima. Võibolla mitte kõikidel teistel lihtsalt Copiga. Kõigepealt see,
Õpetaja: ee, sama asi siit.
Õpetaja: Ta tahab võtta seda hüperlinki. Tuleb Niimoodi teha siniseks Copy siit valikutest võtta. Datasource From Url
Õpetaja: ei pea. Kui te seda klikite, peab isegi pasteima. Ta saab aru, et midagi on clipil ja ta paneb ise siia
Õpetaja: purli ära.
Õpetaja: Nimelt saab ta kohe aru, et tegemist on spordi Numbri võtab ja näeb ka, seda, et ee, andmebaasi nimi peaks olema. Vali It Underscore iga,
Õpetaja: Kohe siis ei ole sul vaja.
Õpetaja: No väga lihtne Kas siin on alla mingi database või mida iganes siin Kui on, siis on olemas jah.
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: midagi taolist? Jah,
Õpetaja: nii, aga kõikidel teistel, kellel ei ole siis kui nüüd, vajutada okeid, siis tuleb lahti, Niuke aken ka väiksemaks. Teha.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt on selle ühenduse nimi Niiöelda mi? Mida? Mis hakkab siin all niiöelda paistma. Mina olen alati pannud selle nimeks lihtsalt
Õpetaja: selle. See nime võib olla mida iganes. See on savi. See on selles mõttes, nagu, et ta ei ole mingi asja Niiöelda määram nagu
Õpetaja: ta. Ei, vaata nüüd kuskil, boss. Kreskust. Midagi niukest sõna Vaata, see on lihtsalt edaspidi niimoodi mugavalt ära toodud.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida Peab käsitsi nüüd ära täitma.
Õpetaja: Mis peaks olema postgress S iga väiksed tähed post
Õpetaja: copida. Võibolla niimoodi näed. See osa
Õpetaja: ja parool peaks olema. See on siis, kui on täpselt nii tehtud. Noh, tal rakendus käima läks. Siis ju Siis on? Peab olema student.
Õpetaja: Üks, kaks, kolm, kõik Väiksed tähed.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas nüüd saab aru, kas kõik on hästi? Siis Test Connection.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta võib nüüd öelda, et, ee, ei ole nagu Mingit ee. Draiverit. Aga ta pakub siis Nuppu. Download Draiverit. Vajutage
Õpetaja: Eesti keele. Küsib draiverit.
Õpetaja: Ee, küsige, aga siis põhimõtteliselt seda test Connection It Vajutades,
Õpetaja: ee, pidi tulema. No sa tagasi saab ka minna.
Õpetaja: Te tahate põhimõtteliselt näha niukest asja?
Õpetaja: See ütleb, et sain ühendust,
Õpetaja: Seda saavad nüüd teised ka proovida. Kuidas teised saavad seda proovida? Veel tagantjärgi. Ee, kõige tõenäolisem. Teil. Kõigil on sellega korras. Niikuinii, aga lihtsalt teha parem klõps Ja Properties mulle ütleb, kas mul ei olekski uuemaid? Kas oli vaja vajutada? Kõik töötas,
Õpetaja: Vahel kahetseb. Ee, et kui minna parem, siis peaks tulema. See sama asi ette, mis saab proovida.
Õpetaja: See tekst, mis siin kirjutab, pole mida iganes kuidagi erinev, aga
Õpetaja: aga põhimõtteliselt huvitab seda, et Ta Ta näeb ära, et on connection.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis veel, ee, oleks? Ee, jah, praegu rohkem samme siin ei ole
Õpetaja: vajutada Okei, kas kellegil Ei ole mingit probleeme.
Õpetaja: Taavi Davai.
Õpetaja: Kui said Rohelise saksiili ette See on kõik, mis me otsime hetkel
Õpetaja: nüüd järgmine asi, mis me tahaks teha on siis see, et kui. Seda siit teha lahti, kas ta näitab teil niukest? Ee,
Õpetaja: niukest asja? Umbes oli idee ja publik, ja
Õpetaja: Mul on sul mingid debit ka. Vaata, kohe vaatame seda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on meil Connection olemas nimega database.
Õpetaja: Nüüd järgmisena. Mis võiks teha lahti, on Siis, ee.
Õpetaja: Paneme korra siit kõik kinni. Teeme natukene väiksemaks Vabandust, dokumendi toks kaustas. Te Saate niimoodi tõmmata kõik kokku sellega
Õpetaja: ja siis tulla Ja teha lihtsalt lahti. Kus on database?
Õpetaja: Siin on kolm Scripti, mida me edaspidi tahame käivitada Kõik järjest. Aga Vaatame kõigepealt seda esimest Script I. Võibolla me peame käsitsi seda tegema.
Õpetaja: Sinu mõttes on niimoodi. Esiteks, kui tuleb selline asi lahti ees, kui veel dialektist, mis see dialekt on
Õpetaja: Eesti keeles. On üks natuke parem sõna kui dialekt.
Õpetaja: Murra murrak. Noh, murrokad panevad nagu mingisugust ee. Panevad üldse mingi hullu Vaata, vist On ju? Räägivad nagu sama keelt. Ei, noh, ma ei tea, kas seto keel on juba ikkagi keel. Kus ta on ikkagi murrak.
Õpetaja: Murrak, onju? Aga neil on ikka eriti hull murrak. Ee, räägime lihtsalt. Kas kui pärnakatest või lõunaeestlastest ka nagu. Noh, selle asemel selle asemel ütleme Tolle aja, Teate küll,
Õpetaja: Lääne.
Õpetaja: Ee, mul on Inglismaal. Kunagi oli üks. Ee, üks, üks paarikene, kes olid sealt kuskilt lõuna poolt. Ee, nad Ütlesid alati tolle
Õpetaja: selle asemel. Ja midagi oli veel nagu. Mis vahvad väljendid, kuidas.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: aga, ee, Mis on põhiline? Asi on see, et tegelikult Enamus mootorite laused on tegelikult, ee, Mingi Ninety Five percent saint. Aga väiksed variatsioonid on.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete mingisuguse asja lahti, siis lihtsalt võib küsida. Vaata, et kas sa tahad ära öelda? Põhimõtteliselt, et, ee. Mis murrakust sina paned,
Õpetaja: on ju? Ta pakub vaikimisi, boss ql I Siis seda võibki vajutada.
Õpetaja: Et siis ta nagu teab edaspidi, et kui sa kirjutad mingit Scripti, kui sul on mingi väike viga sees, vaata, Mis, nagu murrakus ei ole? Siis Ta oskab sulle nagu põhimõtteliselt juba ennem nagu Highlight I teha, et midagi valesti
Õpetaja: selle, kui ta küsib ka Vahel Ta teeb akna lahti, et kas globaalselt või ainult selle projekti mõistes siis lihtsalt valiku teetegi kas. Alati Kõik teie. Projektid on Vaikimisi läinud siin projektis.
Õpetaja: Mina olen pannud. Ee, lihtsalt Global. Sellepärast, et tööarvuti see pole. Kui meil on tööd siin Lhv S, vaata siis, seal oli Vaata, Microsoft oli seal endine taga. Noh, siis ma ei tahaks panna et globaalselt
Õpetaja: käsitle minu Skl faile. Vahet pole, mis projekt Seal Ma paneks projekti lõikes. Ee, siin võib panna globali, Kui ta üldse küsib Seda,
Õpetaja: mida saab sätestada ka alati Nüüd on niimoodi, et Ee, ta. Ta saab aru, et tegemist on. Esiteks, siis, ee. Kõige esimene script, mis siin üldse on,
Õpetaja: on, niimoodi et by the way Statement on selle ühe Ee, selle eraldatud. Siin on kokku kolm lauset. Tegelikult esimene kustutab.
Õpetaja: See Kommentaar on ee väsinud. Ee, selle sõna Public võiks tegelikult asendada,
Õpetaja: mis põhimõtteliselt kustutab ära kõik tabelid konkreetse skeema all.
Õpetaja: Järgmine loob uuesti punkskeema koos vajalike õigustega.
Õpetaja: Viimane Script taastab vajalikud. Need Kommentaarid on savi. Nad võivad selles mõttes ka ära kustutada, onju? Nad on lihtsalt selle jaoks mis teeb. Kustuta ära. Niiöelda eraldi. Te võite Mõelda. Kataloog, pank,
Õpetaja: loo, uuesti kataloog, pank, ja anna pangale kõik õigused.
Õpetaja: See on esimene script, mida me tahaksime käima. Panna. Mõte on, see et vaikimisi. Kui seda ei ole ära määrata kuskile ära määratud, siis ee. Tema läheb vastu, mis on alati igas database olemas. Näete seda siin.
Õpetaja: Aga kui te kasutate mingit õppeprojekti, teete veel mingit kolmandat projekti? Ee, selles. Ee, vali it. Niiöelda andmebaasis näiteks, mida te suure tõenäosusega oma projektide puhul teete, siis teil lähevad seal asjad natukene risti. Vaata, sul on tabel loos. User.
Õpetaja: Teises Skeemas on ka User. Mõte on See, et me teeme nagu eraldatud Space, vaata, kus me toimetame oma tabelitega
Õpetaja: ja te saate siis oma projektides ka lihtsalt muuta need sõnad Pank pank ära millekski muuks.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis Me peame tegema, et hetkel ei ole isegi teil sellist skeemat teie arvutis.
Õpetaja: Ee, saage nüüd ühest asja. Räägime kohe ära. See andmebaas, mis teil lokaalselt jookseb, on teie arvutis. Kõik skriptid, mis jooksevad, on teie arvutis.
Õpetaja: Kui sina lisad pärast läbi süsteemi Mingisuguseid andmeid juurde. Need on sinu andmebaasis. Need ei lähe kuidagi maagiliselt kitta abi ja teistele tiimi liikmetele. Ainukene, asi, mis läheb tiimi liikmetele ja on ühinenud Script I.
Õpetaja: Kus on insert laused? Vaata, et, noh, Lisa. Nagu need andmed on ju kui sa kommit Id need. Ära vaata endal sinna projekti. Siis teistele on see ligipääsetav ja käivitatav nende enda arvutis, et neil võivad ka siis olla samasugused andmed nagu Teil, nüüd, siin ongi see, et kõigepealt selle skripti võiks käivitada.
Õpetaja: Kui teete kõik siniseks ja ohverdate selle peal,
Õpetaja: alati ei tulegi, Ee, Mine temaga siis. Võetud. Control Enter, see on. Üritab käivitada tehtud
Õpetaja: ja kui tuleb ette vaata, siis võib seda vajutada. Nüüd Ta ütleb, et Kuule, aga mis andmebaasi? Ühenduse vastu? Mina hakkan seda script I jooksutama. Sul võib olla mitu andmebaasi ühendust
Õpetaja: erineva sätestusega. Vaata, ta küsib See Database ongi nüüd see nimi, mis ma ennem panin ja siit võib valida. Lihtsalt vahet pole. Selle Scripti vahel pole üldse vahet, mis skeemaga läheb. Muidu skeema on, see, et millised skeemad Ta näeb siin valita, näeb mul praegu
Õpetaja: information. Skeema Pg. Kataloog. Need on jälle nagu kataloogid Mis visuaalselt siin võibolla ei paistagi. Meil on praegu selles mõttes tegelikult pigem Savi. Aa, see default. Skeema töötab väga hästi sellepärast, et loob Skeema
Õpetaja: või minule Tuli siia panka alla. Ma ei tea, kas teile kohe nähtavale tuli või mitte.
Õpetaja: Tuleb või Ei, tule. Vahet pole. Ee, Me lähme igal juhul Properties alla Uuesti Võtame. Kogu selle Connection I. Teeme Properties
Õpetaja: ja siin skeemade all. Me saame valida, et mida meile kuvatakse siin valikus. Ja mida mitte. Mina võtaks kõik asjad nagu esialgu. Lihtsalt tikiks maha.
Õpetaja: See siin, see. Connection.
Õpetaja: Nii siis käimas.
Õpetaja: Võtke kõik esialgu maha ja see valid tee. Tehke lahti. Otsige siit, Kus on ainult pank. Meil on lihtsam, et siin projektis selle Connection projektipõhine. Me Tahame ainult näha, nagu seda kausta andmebaasist nagu pank. Mul on kõige lihtsam Teil on kõige lihtsam mõelda sellest, kui kataloogist või nagu folder Ist paneme. Okei,
Õpetaja: kui nüüd valid, tee lahti teha, siis peaks siin olema ainult pank. Niiöelda Public Ut enam ei ole ja mingeid muid asju ka pole.
Õpetaja: On niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kellel? Jah, Miks sul Ei, ole?
Õpetaja: No selle script I Oh, seda seda script I Jooksutasid Control Enter.
Õpetaja: Aitäh, Tager veel üheks juhuks.
Õpetaja: No ma tulen. Vaatan Maria ja korra. Lihtsalt, ee, jookseb. Kontra mentor.
Õpetaja: Eriti jooksutati Roberti ees Võtame. Kõik maha, Peame Olime siit okei?
Õpetaja: Seal võib tulla versiooni erinevus. Tegelikult on olemas Skeema, peamiselt midagi olemas Mm, jah, mida? Ja jah,
Õpetaja: Kuidas sellist muudatused on teinud.
Õpetaja: Jah, jah, Vaata, Point on nagu see. Vaata, et, ee. Meil on nagu top level.
Õpetaja: Oo, me teeme nüüd nagu selle väga tükreks Onju, Meil on andmebaad.
Õpetaja: See on kast.
Õpetaja: Kogu see asi on ostes,
Õpetaja: mis ma jälgida
Õpetaja: kogu andmebaasi. Mootor. Nüüd vaikimisi. Siin. Sees tavaliselt ongi juba väga kõrgel levelil on nagu, et, ee. Näiteks
Õpetaja: on andmebaas nimega ka koos Yes,
Õpetaja: aga meie Niiöelda Script tekitas tegelikult juurde nagu täiesti Eraldi mängumaa.
Õpetaja: Ma olin Andres ka. Nüüd teen
Õpetaja: nüüd siin sees. On meil ka nüüd. Veel eraldi alaja. Vaikimisi. Tuleb Siia kaasa üks siuke Kassikene, mille nimi on
Õpetaja: Public. See on skeema.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me niiöelda teie siin selle koolituse vältel, niiöelda ee, toimetaksite ainult selles publicust, mis on vaikimisi olemas, ja mille vastu niiöelda päringud lähevad. Me ei ole defineeritud Scriptis. Mis keema vastu ta läheb, on ju
Õpetaja: siis sellisel juhul Kõik Te tabelid. Näiteks teil tuleb üheksa tabelit. Võtame veel ühe värvi.
Õpetaja: Ee, võtame näiteks. Ee. Võtame selle oranži kasutatud Siia võiks tulla tabel Üks ja tema andmed tabel. Kaks nime siia. Ei pane, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga nüüd on see. Vaata, et kui sinul teed tabeli user, Mis on sinu ühe rakenduse jaoks? Ja nüüd pärast te teete näiteks oma tiimiprojekti. Sa teed ka Tabeli user. Vaata siis ta klassib Sellega Te ei saa tulla nagu siis on nagu lihtsam. Kui me vaata seda üldse ei kasuta,
Õpetaja: vaid Teeme käsitsi Ee. Juurde suure kataloogi ja Selle nimeks on siis pank, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ja kui teie teete oma projekt, ma panen oma.
Õpetaja: Te teete ka sellise asja ja kui nüüd Siin Sees on samanimelised tabelid
Õpetaja: või nagu mingisugune tabeli nimi, mis nagu kattub. Vaata,
Õpetaja: siis ei ole. Mingit probleeme. See on nagu oma väike liivakast et
Õpetaja: see on skeema. Iga kord, kui meil on rakendusse kontitud niimoodi, et ta juba lähebki. Ee, andmebaasi vastu andmebaasiline valide ja skeema, Mille vastu ta pöördub, on pank.
Õpetaja: Siis on see ära eraldatud. Kasutatakse seda ka Ongi. Nagu mingid asjad. Nagu eraldatakse. Näiteks paymentsis oli meil Tegelikult ka mida iganes, Aga oli ka mingi muu asi, kus käid mingid muud asjad ja mille vastu said ka minna ja toimetada. Vaata, On ju,
Õpetaja: et see andmebaas on lihtsalt M. Andmebaas.
Õpetaja: Testijatel oli oma andmebaas, Mida me ei näppinud, on ju päriselt kuskil on andmebaas kuhu Keegi nagu naljalt. Keegi ei saa vähemalt pangas mitte, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga teine on ka tarbija klientas.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei. Ja ma arvan, et Data database On Pigem see. Nii
Õpetaja: on see vaikimisel. Kui te installite postgress, siis Enamus juhul naine. Vaata, tuleb, On seal kohe andmebaas nimega postgress.
Õpetaja: Vahel See Ei, tule vaata. Õpetused olid. Ka. Kuidas seda luua? Vaata, onju. Aga No nüüd ma juba läksin seda Teed kursusega, et las siis olla täiesti eraldi andmebaasid.
Õpetaja: No see on ka see, et vaata, et need, kes tulevad oma arvutiga. Vaata, et kas neil juba äkki on Midagi Siis ei sega. Vaata, et täiesti pärast Kustutage kas või kogu database. Valige maha ja ongi kõik
Õpetaja: nii. Meil on nüüd olemas see Pank onju? Ja hetkel siin midagi sees pole. Aga see script selle tegi
Õpetaja: nüüd edaspidi. Meil on võimalik käivitada kolme Scripti korraga, nende mitte Nagu, Vot siin me tulime. Lihtsalt valisime selle nagu need käsud. Ja siis. Kui käsud ja jooksutasime need kolm käsku läks üks, kaks, kolm, Aga nüüd, edaspidi, meil on üldse võimalik niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et kõigepealt selle peale olite Shift I all. Järjekord on tähtis ja valite, et kõik kolm Scripti sooviks käivitada,
Õpetaja: Teeb parema klõpsu.
Õpetaja: Siin on run üks reset database. Ja tegelikult ta tahab neid teisi faili nimesid ka nimetada, et parem Klõps ja run. Ja kui nüüd teha seda natukene laiemaks näed, siin ütleb, et name, mis ta pakub, on reset database and two More
Õpetaja: Me tahame nagu. Et edaspidi selle asja nimi ilmub siia ülesse ka. Vaata, kus Backendi ja Frontend I saab käivitada. Me tahaks teha siia ühe asja juurde, nagu reset
Õpetaja: Tb. Näiteks reset database.
Õpetaja: Nüüd need kolm Scripti. Me tahame nüüd. Ta ütleb, et No not configed data source, Ta ütleb, et. Aga ütle mulle. See Connection seadistus Mille vastu need käivitatakse? Näed, siin on. See on veel täpsem, et siin plussi juurde Peame tulema.
Õpetaja: Meil võib olla mitu Connectionit defineeritud. Siin on see meie database
Õpetaja: ja teeme selle linnukesega lahti. Teeme linnukese ka valitee lahti, senikaua Kuni me leiame ülesse panga.
Õpetaja: Me tahame öelda, et. Hei, need kolm Script, I. Mida sina käivitad, käivitas keema pank suhtes,
Õpetaja: siis seal lausete Sees on mingi sõna ees. Ta teab, kuhu on see suunatud.
Õpetaja: Täpselt sinna. Selle keskmise parempoolse keskmise pihta On ju
Õpetaja: kui te, topeltklõps topeltklõpsuga saab selle valida. Siin peab teil olema selle Connection I nimi, mis siin sai ennem valitud ja vali it punkt pank
Õpetaja: ja nüüd on See, et tema käivitab, siis ta käivitab ja käivitab siin tasuks panna. Kõigepealt Apply.
Õpetaja: Selleks on nimi meelde ja siis vajutage run
Õpetaja: plussi alt valida.
Õpetaja: Pluss sealt. Ee, nii kaugele minna nende lahti, kuni lööb selle panga üles.
Õpetaja: Oota seda seda Step I ei oleks saanud teha, kui Meil seda. Skeemat pank ei ole. Aga mis Esimene script? Kolm rida. Mis ma tekitaski selle skeema scriptiga Andmebaasis, tabeleid, andmeid, Ee, mis Iganes kustutatakse, uuendatakse, luuakse. Ee, muudetakse kõik Script i abil.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd vajutada siia seda runnopuheide, võib ka enne vajutada
Õpetaja: Meelde niikuinii taas muidugi meelde. Kui vajutada run, siis mis tema taustal teeb, on see, et tema nüüd käis Need kolm faili läbi ja igaühe jooksutas. Siin all on Mingi logi ka. Aga me seda isegi ei pea vaatama. Rohkem huvitab see, et resetiga mis ta. Teeb, Ta kustutab skeema pank, kui see eksisteerib ja loob uuesti. Skeema pank.
Õpetaja: Mõte on. See. Vaata, kui me tahame iga kell taastada mingi normaalne seis kus on mingid algandmed ja mingi sisu, siis me saame väga kiirelt seda teha.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete nagu päris süsteemi vaata onju, hakkate vaikselt katsetama. Alguses ehitate teete, te Muutute testides niikuinii laisaks. Vaata, et ei viitsi elu sees enam uue kasutaja registreerimisel mingi meaningful Name panna ja nii edasi hakkab minema kõik. Toimib, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, ja toimetate seal. Siis sellega on võimalik See, et kustutab kogu see Staff. Ära
Õpetaja: loo see tühi kest uuesti ja nüüd See järgmine script on see, et loo vastavad tabelid
Õpetaja: ja sisestage mingi näidisandme, et me saame alati nagu mingisuguse puhta seisu, mis on meile tuttav.
Õpetaja: Ja siis me saame näiteks proovida seal. Mingi lisa asju. Kustutasju on hästi lihtne jälgida asju, et selline nagu lähenemine on, et iga kell nüüd edaspidi Näete. See ei saa ülesse ka.
Õpetaja: Vajutad see, tuled, valid selle. Noh, näed, Paned frondi käima? Tahad näiteks käima? Tahad mingi Hetk nagu teha, et oleks jälle nagu niuke Algseis.
Õpetaja: Tuled siia, paned Play nuppu, Ta ütleb, et kas tahad jälle käivitada seda Scripti ja. Ja seda võib nii palju vajutada. Kui tahad, ta teeb iga kord sama asja. Ta kustutab sisuliselt kõik tabelid ära ja loob nüüd uuesti,
Õpetaja: ma nüüd tasukski vaadata loomist.
Õpetaja: Kui teha see lahti, siis näeme, et siin on niuksed. Script Id võta natukene väiksemaks
Õpetaja: Create Table City nüüd Struktueeritud päringu keel.
Õpetaja: Ee, jumal tänatud. Võrreldes nagu progemisega, kus näiteks jaava ja igast mingid muud asjad. Ee, suht niukene maalähedane keel
Õpetaja: aga jällegi, nagu Iga keelega on vaja teada, et kuidas õiget sõnu õigel ajal rita saada. Ja mõned sümbolid siin seal nagu juurde
Õpetaja: näete, tema skoobi defineerib ära need esimesed sulud. Kui ma panen klikin kuskile mujale klikin siia, kas läheb see siin põlema?
Õpetaja: Huvitav, et Reinbo selle peale ei tööta. Ma oleks arvanud, et Reinbo siin ka on, aga meil on ikka. Vaata, rohelised ja
Õpetaja: Rainbow on kohe saarugi, on ju? Tema ütleb, Et, ee, see päring läheb andmebaasile loo Tabel City.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on süntaks. On selline, et.
Õpetaja: Aa, siis peab kohe tulema Kolumni nimi, tüüp
Õpetaja: ja Mingid seadistused. Näiteks see, et see või tühi olla.
Õpetaja: Nimi, tüüp Varcher varieeruva pikkusega. Tähemärgid, kuni kakssada viiskümmend viis tähemärki natnal
Õpetaja: ja nüüd ütleb Ee, konstrant. Ee, kitsendus.
Õpetaja: See Id peab olema Primer Ig.
Õpetaja: Selle abil on võimalik leida üles mistahes rida.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb ee semi kolon, mis lõpetab selle statement I ära. Great City saab siin otsa,
Õpetaja: aga ma teeks seda käsitsi. Praegult
Õpetaja: saame vaadata. Ka mina teen siin korra vaatamise kohta. Kui te praegu tulete, vaatate, siis te saate vaadata database all. Kui te teete panga lahti, te näete. Teil peaks olema. Ütleb, et on üheksa
Õpetaja: vastable.
Õpetaja: Need tabelid on teil loodud?
Õpetaja: Okei, hüppan korra natuke edasi. Tabelid on teil loodud? Ja teil on ka mingisugused algandmed, mis Tulevad sellest importfailist.
Õpetaja: Siin on insertlaused.
Õpetaja: Vaatame seda sama City Incert into skeema pank. See on see must kast Tabel. City
Õpetaja: Nüüd on konkreetne Insert süntaks sulgude seest. Määra ära. Veerud Id ja name
Õpetaja: ja peale väljust vä komadega ükshaaval väärtused. Ideile läheb vaikimisi väärtus ja nimeks läheb Pärnu, siis tuleb Tallinn Tartu.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis selle kahe kahe Scripti peale kokku. Kui me vaatame andmebaasi Citytabelit topelt lahti siin klikiga,
Õpetaja: sest ta näitab, et City tabel on hetkel sellise seisuga.
Õpetaja: Kui ma võtan selle niiöelda vilbasteks, ma teen korra reset database. See esimene script lööb platsi puhtaks.
Õpetaja: Create Script loob Tabeli City.
Õpetaja: Nuuksutan seda.
Õpetaja: Aa ei taha The False Gema Tahan jooksutada seda skeema pank vastu.
Õpetaja: Nii, ee, proovin uuesti, Ee, kõigepealt resetiga. Löön kogu platsi puhtaks.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaatan, kas on tabeleid. Ei, ole.
Õpetaja: Teen Tabeli City. Jooksutan seda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd teen Refresh I ajaks. Üks, tulen vaatan. Panga all on üks Tabel City
Õpetaja: City tabel. Koos Tühjade väärtustega Veel ei ole ühtegi rida.
Õpetaja: See selle asja jaoks on olemas Selline asi nagu Sequents Counter automaatselt ise andmebaas. Selle tegi selle sama pealt, et ma ütlesin see, et
Õpetaja: kus see siin on, et See on Primer I Gi
Õpetaja: Primeri Ghee jaoks Tehti siia alla üks Loendur City Id Sequence counter.
Õpetaja: Noh, tuletan meelde korra. Mäletate, kui me Vaatasime seda Exceli faili.
Õpetaja: See on see pluss üks teema.
Õpetaja: Teen korra lahti.
Õpetaja: Vale, siis äkki tabelid teise ära kustutada. Üldse
Õpetaja: mäletate seda? Näete, Siin on City Tallinn, Tartu pärnu. Mäletate seda asja
Õpetaja: seda välja? Meie ei täida vaid vaikimisi. Väärtus tuleb siia. Saame väärtused panna.
Õpetaja: Nii temal ongi siin see Chickens Counter.
Õpetaja: Ma ei saa seda väärtust kuidagi näidata. Vaata aga ta on. On ju
Õpetaja: ja see on niimoodi, et kui City S. Ma tean, teen siin Visuaalselt Saab ka teha. Vaata, ma saan ise. Seda tööriista saab kasutada. Taustal lähevad Esko veel päringud? Ma ütlen. Tee üks uus rida. Midagi veel ei ole juhtunud. Seda mina ei täida. Siia ma võin panna. Näiteks Pärnu
Õpetaja: Enter ka veel midagi ei tee. Kui sa teed siin submit.
Õpetaja: Korra tõmban. Ee, siit nagu mina Panen praegu nüüd siit submit, Siis läheb Sql Käsk, insert, Indupank City.
Õpetaja: Hakkame täitma Vr. Ka Id ja name väärtused
Õpetaja: selle esimesele default Väärtus Sellele name Ile läheb Pärnu see lause tegelikult taustal tegi andmebaasi andmed Mitte see, et ma vajutasin siin nuppe,
Õpetaja: teeb lihtsalt minu eest seda Script I.
Õpetaja: Ma sain siit teisi asju ka teha, Ma saan uue tabeli teha. Näiteks New Table.
Õpetaja: Isegi see New Table taustal ikkagi teeb. Script I. Näiteks selle City Tabeli peal. Kui ma tulen parema Klõpsu teen ja vaatan Tema ütleb, et näed. Sina saad sellise tabeli teha. Natuke lühem kirjaviis.
Õpetaja: Kakssada viiskümmend viis nathnal
Õpetaja: ja Lisa, et postgress saab seda kasutada. No see on mingi mõtte asi, mida ma praegu ei räägi.
Õpetaja: Et kogu suhtlus andmebaasiga käib jällegi läbi mingisuguse keele
Õpetaja: Nüüd See ei ole enam nagu, ee, Niukene programmeerimis keel, et ta on Script.
Õpetaja: Ta käib nagu rida Realt Linnu Lennuk aina teeb lihtsalt asja Üks rida teise järgi
Õpetaja: ja lihtsalt. Meil on see mugavamalt siin tehtud. Vaata, et siin impordis on juba kenasti olemas.
Õpetaja: Aga ma teen uuesti korra reelset database.
Õpetaja: Lasen selle siit alla. Ütlen, et Lowlin
Õpetaja: nii vaatan. Linnatabel loodi ja hetkel on ta tühi, aga siis, kui see Kolmas Gripp käivitub ja käivitub see osa, et Pank City Näed see siin
Õpetaja: siis Insert Into Bank. Kõigepealt pärnu Tallinn Tartu, Id. Sid ise ei Pane need tulevad vaikimisi siia. Niimoodi ei taha panna nagu üks. Miks ei taha ise panna siia väärtuseid?
Õpetaja: Ja kui mina panen siia kolm väärtust praegult ise ära vaata. On null, on nii, onju? Mina panen sinna pärnu. Ma teen Control Setiga. Vaatasin ennem, just oli
Õpetaja: nii kui ise käsitsi panna. Nii, üks ja pärnu, Kaks ja Tallinn, kolm ja Tartu siis on kogu aeg null. Null, null. Nüüd, kui ükskord programmiliselt Meie rakendus hakkab midagi lisama. Paneme siia näiteks viljandi,
Õpetaja: Mis ta teeb? Tuleb paneb selle pluss ühe peale. Saab Ühe väärtuse, Tahab siia panna Ühte ee
Õpetaja: ei saa, sest et üks on juba olemas.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see sai sinna pandud. Aga mitte default väärtusega. Seepärast on hästi tähtis, Et me ise neid väärtuseid kunagi kriitika ei paneks.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast Chickens Counter ei suurene, vaid peab olema. Niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Default. Default default. Ma võin seda läbi näidata teile. No ma teengi niimoodi üks, kaks, kolm, hetkel. Siin City all. Refresh in ei ole midagi. Ei ole. Käivitan selle Scripti
Õpetaja: Põmm The Folk Connection
Õpetaja: ja tulen siia City peale. Teen Refresh I näitab, et on väärtused, on nii? Proovin panna siia viljandi
Õpetaja: mida ta, Praegu üritab panna see, kui ma löön läbi selleks ühe, Vaatame, mis siit välja tuleb.
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen, et, ee, sada sõnum unique constraint Ee, Key one Already existed.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtleks nagu. Vau, mis on? Aga, vau, ma lihtsalt tahan viljandi panna. Mis sul viga on? Paneme teise Korra
Õpetaja: kaks Exists ja neljandaga läheb läbi
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ta jõudis lõpuks Counteriga nii kaua kaugele, mis ei konflikti varasemate väärtustega, mis on tabelis, aga seda siis vältida. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: te hakkate ise. Saate ka andmeid andmebaasi normaalselt niimoodi lisada läbi selle ui.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, kui see sama asi näiteks Kus ma selle sain? Noh, Ma tahan pärnu. Tallinn Tartu viljandi. Palun väga.
Õpetaja: Siit tabelist. On võimalik andmeid eksportida
Õpetaja: Vaikimisi ta on. Mina tahan eksporti teha, siis ta ütleb, et näed. Palun väga. Tahad niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Tahad, et On niimoodi Column Header Id juures
Õpetaja: Mul on nagu see, et, Ee, ma tahan. Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Aga vaadake, mis täna teeb. Reip väljus. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu võtan selle ja mõtlen. Ohoo, väga Hea tšilli pilli. Ee, lähen siia oma importi ja panen põmm.
Õpetaja: Noh, oota, sa praegu kõik töötab. Ma käivitan selle Scripti. Kõik töötab, Fine, Ma teen reset data.
Õpetaja: No probleem on. Teen panga lahti. Kõik üheksa Tabelit City on olemas andmed on olemas programmiliselt Jõuan sinna maani, kus saaks mingit linna lisada. Tahan panna.
Õpetaja: Mm, rapla.
Õpetaja: Ee. Aga kujutage ette, see juba nüüd juhtub niimoodi, et ka programmis üritate. Seda. Te olete ära programmeerinud mingisuguse asja teenuse teinud, kasvatates ägeritelt proovida. Näiteks on ju? Tuleb mingi error, mis tuleb juba koodist juba et ei saa. Noh, Tuleb mingi sama tekst, kellel on niimoodi, et. Oi, minu arust on midagi valesti programmeerinud.
Õpetaja: Kohe ei tea. Vaata, Ei, ole veel kogemust,
Õpetaja: Niukene. Asi on nagu. Väga, nagu spetsiifiline viga.
Õpetaja: Ja siis on see kõige rõvedam. Asi Töötab, ei tööta. Las ma proovin siis uuesti vajutada. Svägeris Nuppu ei tööta. Ei tööta, ei tööta, tööta.
Õpetaja: Nal on siin kogemata. Ma pean korra selle ära kustutama. Nallida ei saa sinna panna. Ee, Ta korra taustal muutis seda asja.
Õpetaja: Lähme uuesti.
Õpetaja: No ta isegi ei suuda seda panna. Praegu vahet pole mõttest. Saate aru, et ee, pigem On nagu parem nagu seda osa. Nagu vältida, et isegi kui sa võtad kuskilt skrip I, vaata siis nagu teed fookus. Fookus
Õpetaja: seda Pean ka näitama teile, kuidas niimoodi üle mitme rea kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, ainult on vaja meeles seda hoida,
Õpetaja: sest muidu Secondscounter Eid lihtsalt ei söö ta ära andmete seastamisel. Nüüd süüakse ma.
Õpetaja: No tahate kohe teada või vanasti teksti manipuleerimist? Isegi kui ma tegin mingi muu taimed niiöelda pidin kuidagi hästi süsteemselt muutma asju. Siis ma tegin tellid sees lahti.
Õpetaja: Oh, see on Niukene Alt vist, onju.
Õpetaja: Teen nagu siia kliki.
Õpetaja: Kliki ei ole Alt shift.
Õpetaja: Kuskilt hakkab pihta. Vaata, üks praegu. Aa, esimene peab paigas olema Üks shift i alt. Kaks,
Õpetaja: kolm, neli ee. Nüüd näiteks noortega Saad liikuda ka, kui tahad shift i peal hoida.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes, Ee saad teha. Niimoodi ka Hoiad shift i alti uuesti peale. Aga klikid Sõna, sõna, sõna, sõna.
Õpetaja: Seal on ainult see. Vaata, kui midagi üle kirjutad, siis võitad entrit.
Õpetaja: Aga kui sa vajutad entrit, siis ta lükkab Igale reale. Vahere, et sa lihtsalt kirjutad selle sõna valmis ja. Ja et sellest režiimist lahkuda. Vaata mul üles alla Saan ka liigutada, vaata Kuidagi sealt ülevalt lähevad need. Mitu joont,
Õpetaja: Mismoodi
Õpetaja: Kas ta jääb topeltük
Õpetaja: Võibolla sa mingil hetkel nägid midagi, mis isegi oli tõene, aga see Ei ole nagu see peamine asi. Peamine asi on see, et saaksite aru, et te saate pärast hiljem ka endale. Noh, räägime seda veel Ka homme tahakski. Tegelikult Soome praegu natukene juba algust teha. Saage aru, vaata kõik need käsud, mis siin on
Õpetaja: neid käske Tegelikult, ee. See. See on nagu väga ekslik. On nagu see, et Niuke tunne tekib. Vaata et see,
Õpetaja: et et see intellige, ei teeb siin neid asju kõike ja otse Suhtleb kuidagi andmebaasiga. Ei suhtle otse andmebaasiga
Õpetaja: meie eest. Lihtsalt teeb neid käske. Me saame iga kell ise teha. Lahti, ee Omal ee siit database ist
Õpetaja: jump to query consol Te. Console late
Õpetaja: see konsoli ma. Võin trükkida mida iganes
Õpetaja: ee. Sul võib olla kaasa Vaatamise koht. See on aega niikuinii vähe. Vaata, on ju, mida me tahame läbi käia üliväiksel kujul. Me ei ole Skl Koolitus see on Kõige lihtsam asi, mida te saate ka kuskilt pudemist või kust iganes õppida. Mingi Skl Basic käsklused
Õpetaja: see on nagu kui ma muidu ütlen. Vaata teile, et ärge midagi uut võtke. Vaata, kui te selle koolituse lõpetate, ärge hakka kuusi tehnoloogiaid vaatama, siis on ainukene Erand
Õpetaja: et eeskuju all on igal pool.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole ka, mis roll. Oled seal Analüütik projektijuht. Mida iganes Niikuinii hakkate andmebaasis asju vaatama võiks osata, eriti kui et arendaja. Vaata, et ikkagi on vaja vaadata, mida me tahame läbi käia. Sk helistab kommentaaride ja niukse topelt.
Õpetaja: Me tahame teha kõik, ee Need toimingud läbi kruud. Mis need kruudid olid?
Õpetaja: Nii, Kuidas on kreit? Ee, siin. Meil Skl is profe. Ikka on siin juba.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab lisada andmeid.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas saab andmeid lugeda?
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab andmeid uuendada? Ülekirjutada?
Õpetaja: Okei, no mingi tähtki.
Õpetaja: Tubli. Tubli Jaroslav Kas sa hakkisid selle siit lahti. Vaata või?
Õpetaja: Nii et siis, on kaks tükki? Vaata, on insert ja selector niuksed. Asjad, mida veits meeles olid, on ju? Ja siin Ongi selline süntaks, et kui mul on siin selles tööriistas keema Ise valitud. Juba valid tee ja pank,
Õpetaja: siis ta ise. Arvestab et ta ise paneb selle skeema iga lause juurde ette, on ju? Aga kui seda ei ole,
Õpetaja: et ei ole öeldud, siis on, niimoodi, et kui Mina tahan mingeid andmeid. Ee, ma. Ma ei hakkaks andmet insertima, sest ma hakkaks praegu sellest Selectist pihta. On ju,
Õpetaja: et andmed Meil on See Citytabel, mis me just nägime. Meil on muud tabelit ka. Me võime varsti neid vaadata. Mõttes oli meil ee, mis meil olid need Kaks tabelit,
Õpetaja: puser ja rool. Ma vaatan kõigepealt rooli ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis asja vaatame? Vaatan siin Samas
Õpetaja: Siin on nüüd see, ka, et mis Mulle meeldis database tool juba ammu ennem. Kõik teised kasutasid mingit ja niukseid. Sql. Niiöelda programme on väga palju, millega on väga päringu võimalik Vaadata Sisu ja. Ja. Nii edasi. Mulle meeldib see Predictive Stuff. Kolme tähe peale tuleb templeid
Õpetaja: Select all Roast From Table Davai, siis Select all Rose
Õpetaja: kõik veerud on ee. Wildcardiga Asterix
Õpetaja: from Table. Noh, Kui mul ei ole pandud skeemat paika, siis skeema on ei ole skeimasiti Pank,
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea. Nüüd vaata. Siit on ikkagi see asi tuksi läinud. Ma ei oska seda kuidagi neutraalseks enam teha.
Õpetaja: No vist ikkagi läks. Nüüd vaata. Pank või Mis ee tabelit ta pangas näeb?
Õpetaja: No kui ma võtan Role, mis meid huvitab,
Õpetaja: anna mulle kõik, nagu panen kõik inimesed, Pin Pim, pim, pim, pimm.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ütlen, et jooksult on selline Script tegi siin alltabeli.
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: Ee, control enter ee ta Võtab nagu. Mis rea peal oled. Kui sa selekteerid mingi imeliku osa, siis ta võid proovida ka seda jooksutada ja ütleb, et kuule Ei,
Õpetaja: Ma tavaliselt olen nagu selle peal. Näed, see roheline markeerib ära. Vaata, on ju? Kui ma panen siin Control Enter, siis ta jooksutab seda Üks variant on ka. Ineditor. Resource on see, et ära tee siia alla aknasse, vaid pane kohe siia. Alla. Näiteks Control Enter.
Õpetaja: Panin siia alla niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kui ei taha seda, siis lihtsalt lülitad selle välja. Niiöelda riigiga saab selle kuidagi ära siit saada. Mul praegu isegi niimoodi on Lihtsam
Õpetaja: Pank on üks tabel.
Õpetaja: Ja siis ma panen Select Sl.
Õpetaja: Ee, from pank, Punkt User. Need on need kaks tabelit.
Õpetaja: Keegi on, ma Ei tea, see tuleb kaasa. Lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: Ee. Ei, see on hea. Vaata, võibolla see asi ei tööta. Või mida iganes see on parem.
Õpetaja: Vot Pead kõik kirjutama ise
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: siin üks asi. Lihtsalt ma näitan ära User. Tabel on jutumärgid Ee. Il on endal ka mingi seal engine Is Endas on ka mingi tabel user,
Õpetaja: et siin nagu escape Ida seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on ikka üks väikene vimka, mida peaks teadma, Okei,
Õpetaja: Noh, Ee, meie rollis siin. On või? Sellel? Meie. Siin ongi vaja teada. Vaata, mis oli vaja vaadata.
Õpetaja: Ee, oli vaja vaadata sisselogimisel kasutajanimi Ja Baroo ja aktiivsus Kas leiad tagastama? Peab user Id, palun. Väga usertabeli.
Õpetaja: Ühtlasi peab tagastama.
Õpetaja: Noh, see üks viitab. Vaadake, nüüd. On võtmed Variant Swetti.
Õpetaja: Sinine võti.
Õpetaja: Mul värvid Hoidsin ära sealt.
Õpetaja: Primary Gee on kollane võti. Foreign Key, mis viitab mingi teise tabeli Primer I le on sinine võti
Õpetaja: parengii. Neid värve tuleb veel kuskil siin, seal.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis on niimoodi, et minul on vaja teada lõppkokkuvõttes, et kes sa Oled Id na. Ja mis on sinu roll
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas toimetab, on see. Vaata nüüd, tuleb see relatsiooniline andmebaas välja.
Õpetaja: Sul on Alati selles mõttes entrion. Ühe tabeli mõttes.
Õpetaja: Kui mina Tahaksin praegult nagu kombineerida kahe tabeli andmeid, aga ma tahaksin saada kõiki ridu, mis on Ühes tabelis.
Õpetaja: Kumma tabel. Kummast tabelist ma alustaksin,
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin saada kätte kõik kasutajad ja vaadata sealt mingeid andmeid, siis mind tegelikult huvitab Ridade mõttes see,
Õpetaja: et ma peaksin ütlema Select from user.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, kui ma küsiksin Ee, Select From Role Banks siis maksimum ridu, mis esialgses Filtreerimissõelal jääb, on kaks,
Õpetaja: aga minul on üldse vaja neid vaadata. On ju, et praegult see Select From Pan kuser mind aitab ainult nii palju, et. Ee, ma saan. Need Tabelid, mida ma Ukraina nagu tahaksin teha, on see, et siin lõpus oleks juures veel veerg
Õpetaja: Ee, Id Role Id ja Role name.
Õpetaja: Tahaksin. Vaata, et et need numbrid üks, kaks, kaks, rehkenduksid. Admin ja Customer on lõppeesmärk saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: ja Nüüd tuleb siis selle andmebaasi nagu eriline võlu välja, et selle asemel, et lihtsalt nagu küsida.
Õpetaja: Okei, ma jätan korra selle ette, vaata, onju, Ma teen siia Tabeli ühe Select lause alla juurde, onju? See on ikkagi viimane asi, mis me täna jõuame teha. Ma ütlen, et jah, Võta mulle põhimõtteliselt. Ee, Pangast Ee, user tabelist kõik read. Noh, See tagastaks mulle praegult nii, nagu see ülemine tabelki on.
Õpetaja: Aga Mina tahan nüüd öelda, et. Kuule, Aga ole nii nunnu viida, Palun need väärtused Tabeliga pank
Õpetaja: ja anna mulle need andmed ka.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan öelda, et Ole hea, join.
Õpetaja: Ta juba pakub mulle praegult ise siin. Ee, variante ette ka. Ja ma kavatsen kasutada. Ta ei tea mis Tabeliga ma Soovin ee niiöelda. Ee, join ida. Ma tahan seda, et. Hei, rollitabeliga. Ee, vaata. Liida user tabelile
Õpetaja: ette külge tabel role kasvatajale, edaspidi Nüüd Viitame sellele role tabelile Rtähe Abil. See on nagu muutuja nimi
Õpetaja: ja liida nad Niimoodi See on üks ühele suhe, kus role tabel ja Id võrdub usertabeli Role Id. Ehk Ma paneksin sellele ka. Siis me saame tekitada siia tähelepu. Usertabelil võiks olla tähtpuu
Õpetaja: Role. Tabeli võiks edaspidi Viidata tähega, R. Saate aru? Selline väike konstruktsioon on. Ja mina tahan öelda, et role Id
Õpetaja: role id C, role, Id peab võrduma u User
Õpetaja: Id. Vabandust, user tabelist veel. Growl Id.
Õpetaja: Me võrdleme kahte numbrit, et ühenda need tabelid nende abil saate mõttest aru
Õpetaja: ja kui ma Nüüd jooksutan selle käsu. Siis te näete, et siia lõppu tuleb kaks veergu juurde. Rida Tarbijab samaks.
Õpetaja: Control Enter.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Esimesel poolel on user User, user, user.
Õpetaja: Kuni siiamaani ja lõppu tulid mul ka
Õpetaja: Need veerud. Siit kaks tabelit. Ühendasime omavahel ja nüüd andmed on käes ja nüüd Selle selekti juures on üldse see, et kas ma tahan kõike veerge näha? Ei, ma tahan näha user tabelist. Id D, user, Id
Õpetaja: ja Ma tahan näha koma role tabelist.
Õpetaja: Ee, name i role. Name palun väga.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina otsin.
Õpetaja: Sellist ma täna ei tee. Vaata, me ei. Jõua. Ee, küll Me vaatame seda edasi. See Niukene väikene tipp oli sinna sisse.
Õpetaja: Homme jätkan.